mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour le rhin à la cote d' alerte à
strasbourg le rhône pratiquement la même
hauteur de hameaux isolés en
seine-et-marne près de coulommiers la
plupart des rivières sont sorties de
leurs lits voilà donc les premières
conséquences de dix journées de pluie et
surtout de redoux en effet inondations
en plaine mais avalanche en montagne et
l'avalanche de tignes après midi a fait
finalement quatre victimes dont deux
enfants deux parisiens deux frères et
soeurs de 15 et 13 ans pendant 48 heures
encore nous annonce la météo il y aura
un grand danger d'avalanches en montagne
aussi je crois que le seul conseil à
donner c'est de vous rappeler si vous
êtes à la neige qu'il est indispensable
de respecter les avis autorisé des
responsables des stations qui savent eux
où et quand peuvent se produire les
avalanches n'a fait rire at il cherché
des armes en union soviétique c'est la
question qu'on peut se poser à nouveau
ce matin
en effet bien humble caire le président
américain le président nixon a répondu à
monsieur kossyguine à l'avertissement de
moscou exactement
nixon refuse dans cette réponse moscou
d'endosser la responsabilité de
l'aggravation de la crise isla israélo
arabe il rappelle le chef du
gouvernement soviétique que les états
unis s'étaient déclarés favorables dans
le passé à des pourparlers sur une
limitation des armements au moyen-orient
allant plus loin le président nixon
aurait même relancé dans sa réponse
l'idée d'un embargo total sur les
fournitures d'arbres de quantel qu'il a
été préconisée en son temps par le
général de gaulle
dans son message le suc aussi guînes
laissé planer la menace de nouvelles
fournitures d'armes à l'aer a eu si les
états unis livret de leur côté des
avions trente hommes et skyrock à israël
et si également les forces israéliennes
ne réduisait pas leurs attaques en
profondeur contre le territoire égyptien
devant l'augmentation de l'activité des
organisations de résistance
palestinienne le gouvernement israëlien
prendra-t-il la décision de fermer les
pompes sur le jourdain
une commission parlementaire israélienne
va étudier ce problème la décision sera
laissé à madame golda meir écoutant ce
sujet gérard ce pas peu après la fin de
la guerre des six jours le général moshe
dayan ne fut le grand partisan de
l'ouverture des ponts damian et allenby
entre israël et la jordanie
la libre circulation des personnes
surtout pour la réunion des femmes
des deux côtés du jourdain était pour
lui un élément indispensable au retour à
la confiance des réfugiés vis-à-vis de
l'état hébreu depuis sur le pont allenby
à un trafic intense et installer chaque
jour des dizaines de camions
transportant surtout des produits
agricoles passe pas si la ligne de
cessez-le-feu non plus des produits
agricoles ces camions aux transports
parfois cachés parmi les marchandises
les armes et des explosifs utilisés par
les commandos palestiniens
cette politique du général moshe diana a
été attaqué à la knesset par un député
de la droite de soutenir qui affirme que
ces échanges ne font qu'encourager la
contrebande d armes et l'extension des
mouvements terroristes dans les zones
occupées prise à partie le général moshe
diana répondu qu une politique libérale
accompagné d'un risque était préférable
à une politique de rigueur qui de toutes
les façons ne pouvait mettre fin au
terrorisme
si la commission parlementaire décidé
cette fermeture cela serait considéré
comme un échec de la politique du
général nyan dans les territoires
occupés aussi aujourd'hui d'un envol
caire c'est l'ouverture de négociations
entre la pologne et l'allemagne de
l'ouest
oui c'est la première fois que de tels
notre conversation au niveau des
ministres enfin des secrétaires d'état
que ces conversations ont lieu depuis la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale les
conversations débuté à 10h ce matin au
ministère des affaires étrangères à
varsovie
nous on s'en doute des détails à la fin
de cette journée d'autre part le conseil
des ministres des six reprend ses
travaux à bruxelles cet après midi après
une pause de 24 heures les ministres de
l'agriculture auront à leurs côtés les
ministres des finances et des affaires
étrangères
ces négociations vont porter une fois de
plus sur le règlement financier de
l'europe verte
à ce propos à propos de l'agriculture un
reportage de notre station de londres
sur le malaise et l'école qui règne en
ce moment en grande bretagne ces
manifestants ce sont des paysans anglais
en colère une colère bien anglais
c'est-à-dire bien pondéré bien modéré
mais cette fois assez sérieuse depuis
quelques temps en effet les paysans
anglais ont pris l'habitude de monter à
londres pour exprimer leur
mécontentement
ce n'est d'ailleurs distiller qu'un
commencement bientôt nous allons
paralyser tout le centre de la capitale
pourquoi ce malaise paysan et bien les
cultivateurs anglais estime que le prix
de leurs produits ne sont plus adaptés
du tout au coût de la vie jusqu'à
présent on est aligné ici en ce qui
concerne les prix
et agricoles sur les produits du
commonweath une demi livre de beurre
australien par exemple coûte quelque
chose comme un franc c'est peu le
gouvernement favorise cette importation
concurrentiel et bloque les prix
intérieurs mais demain demain tout peut
changer tout peut basculer
l'entrée de la grande-bretagne dans le
marché commun en tout cas va changer
bien des choses
l'angleterre ne pourra pas continuer à
acheter tout son beurre en australie
sinon en payant des droits d'entrée au
marché commun extrêmement important
alors disent les paysans anglais il est
temps de revoir tout de suite nos prix
et nos marchés en fonction de l'europe
cette paysannerie anglaise n'est pas
très importante elle ne représente que
5% de la population contre quelque chose
comme 10 7% en france je crois mais en
tout cas elle est bien organisée
suffisamment organisés pour sentir qu'un
vent européens est déjà en train de
souffler sur l'angleterre et qu'il est
temps de hisser la bonne voie en france
deuxième journée du congrès du parti
communiste ne l'a commencée à 9h10
exactement la discussion sur le rapport
présenté hier par georges marchais
secrétaire à l'organisation du parti ces
discussions se poursuivent des
interventions des délégations étrangères
seront prévues pour cet après-midi ce
qui veut dire qu'on parlera sans doute
ce matin encore beaucoup de monsieur
gare aux tic mais sûrement
d'autre part attention si vous devez
prendre un avion en effet grève des
mécaniciens au sol d'air france et à
partir de 17 heures ce soir il y aura
pas mal de perturbations sur les moyen
courriers
tous les long courriers sont assurés à
l'exception de ceux pour washington et
los angeles new york et los angeles new
york et los angeles oui en revanche sur
les moyens courriers il peut y avoir des
avions annulés il est préférable de
téléphoner si vous deviez prendre un
avion d'air france
avant ce soir dimanche dernier à colmar
vous vous en souvenez de ministre des
appels me sens désormais monsieur michel
debré 2010 la défense nationale avait
rappelé qu'il n'était pas question de
supprimer le service militaire mais
qu'on pourrait le ramener à 12 mois en
revanche on reparle toujours autant de
la création d'un service civique
à tel point que monsieur missoffe ancien
ministre de la jeunesse et des sports
vient de déposer une proposition de loi
en ce sens en quête de claude carré
vous êtes pour ou contre un service
civique a priori je serais plutôt pour
je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus
positif qu'un service militaire
évidemment pour pourquoi dans la mesure
où c'est pour aider les gens et ces
pauses seront utiles ne nous avez pas
vous êtes pour le service musique mais
enfin pas une durée de 6 mois ou quinze
mois six mois au régime aurait offert
six mois de service mais six mois de
service où on en a donc ce qu'il soit
utile où on apprend le maniement des
armes et où est ce dur que six mois 77 %
des garçons de 20 ans choisirait
d'effectuer un service d'intérêt
national plutôt qu'un service militaire
c'est le résultat d'un sondage effectué
par l'ifop en 1966 récemment monsieur
missoffe ancien ministre de la jeunesse
et des sports a déposé un projet de loi
visant à instituer un service civique
le service civique national et par une
option du service national 10
actuellement le service militaire est
une option le chéri de la coopération
indeed secondes et le service civique
apparaîtrait comme une troisième pion du
service national
en quoi consiste un service civique
alors le service civique dur le même
temps que le service national bien
évidemment et il est appliqué un certain
nombre de tâches qui elles ne peuvent
pas être remplis actuellement et en
aucun cas les applications du service
civique ne doit venir concurrencer le
marché du travail venait le problème des
hôpitaux par exemple ce problème là
incontestablement aurait besoin d'être
pris sur le plan humain on est bien
soigné mais qu'est ce qu'on fait à
l'hôpital on pourrait faire beaucoup de
choses pendant qu'on se soigne prenez le
problème des incendies de forêt tous les
envois des centaines d'hectares brûlés
il y aurait quelque chose à faire pour
éviter des coupures organisée bref si
vous voulez les applications sont très
nombreuses est ce que la jeune fille
serait également concerné moi je crois
qu'il faudrait que les jeunes filles le
soir je crois qu'il faudrait qu'elle
puisse le refuser si elles ne veulent
pas le faire
pourquoi institué ce service civique
national maintenant est ce que le
service militaire est dépassé
le service militaire je crois est une
nécessité mais il est certain que les
besoins de l'armée sont surtout du
besoin de techniciens à l'heure actuelle
madame massue les pousses du général
massu défend avec vigueur le service
militaire actuelle mais il est certain
que pendant 16 mois
les soldats font tout autre chose que
des peluches et des patates peut-être
pas assez je n'en sais rien chaque fois
qu'il ya une catastrophe nationale c'est
bien l'armée qui est appelé et puis même
sans parler de catastrophe nationale
le soldat quand il passe par la main
d'armé apprend beaucoup de choses il y à
un effort de promotion sociale qui est
fait dans l'armée non je crois qu'il
faudrait voir la question un peu plus
près au moment où cette société dans
laquelle nous vivons est une société qui
est contesté ce serait sans doute le
moment court beaucoup de jeunes de
coopérer à essayer de restaurer un
certain nombre des valeurs humaines
auxquelles il croit juste titre
d'ailleurs je crois qu'ils achètent la
jeunesse un énorme besoin d'enthousiasmé
les jeunes le prouve d'ailleurs à peu
près quotidiennement
en tout cas je vous rappelle que c'est
une proposition de loi de la part de
l'ancien ministre monsieur miss trente
sept orphelins c'est le bilan c'est un
autre aspect du bilan du coup de grisou
qui a tué hier à fouquières lez lens 16
mineurs et en a blessé 12 autres la mine
il faut le dire avait été récemment
modernisé les règlements d'autre part
semble avoir été respectée aussi ce
matin tous les mineurs se pose la même
question pourquoi quelle est la cause de
ce coup de grisou ils sont même moins 6
ans mettront mais d'après vous quelles
sont les causes là les causes de
l'accident
pour l'instant il est assez difficile de
porter un jugement
d'après les renseignements que j'ai pu
obtenir un violent
le port le quartier était descendue plus
tôt le matin pour effectuer un
changement de ventilateur alors pour
changer ce ventilateur il a fallu bien
sûr arrêter celui qui était en marche
cette opération ckoi a duré certainement
autour de deux heures or ce n'est pas à
l'arrivée du personnel du poste 6 heures
selon cette réparation n'était pas
terminée or les cornes ne viennent pas
de ce qu'on aurait pu remettre
brutalement le moteur en route
le sentier est arrêté il certains qui
s'est accumulée du grisou offrant du du
sentier faute à cette fois ce n'est pas
varié de la mangue et youtube avait
ajouté ainsi quand même franchement pas
franchement douteuse mais que 18 heures
enfin nous n'aurons pas décédé
dernièrement des toners assez importante
de grisou pouvoir dire qu'il y avait
vraiment de grisou est important mais
alors les causes des causes on peut pas
directement maintenant si on écarte
vraiment c'est d'après les
renseignements obtenus une ventilateur
n'a pas été remise en route de celui
qu'on va changer
or il faut chercher les causes ailleurs
alors d'après vous d'après moi
difficile pour l'instant est ce qu'il ya
eu une tuyauterie qui a claqué qui a
permis comme ça à l'air de s'échapper
on t'a qu'avec le grisou a provoqué
l'explosion mais ce qui est certain ce
que l'on sait avec certitude c'est que
le service de sécurité a fonctionné hier
avec le maximum de rapidité mais les
premiers sauveteurs arrivés quelques
minutes après l'accident n'ont pu sauver
vous le savez que qu'une douzaine de
blessés puisque l'on parle des premiers
secours on en parlait déjà tout à
l'heure un peu avec monsieur miss à
propos du service civique
il faut noter and rebel qu'il ya un gros
effort fait actuellement en faveur de
cette éducation de secourisme qu'on
pourrait apprendre par exemple dès
l'école primaire
en effet je suis fils de secourisme
n'étant pas obligatoire encore chaque
directeur de lycée ou de cours privés
peut faire appel à un instructeur de la
croix rouge
le cal céder place dans ces classes par
contre en province les jeunes peuvent
s'adresser à la préfecture et demande à
la direction de la protection civile et
à ce moment là ils ont du coup des gens
qui viennent leur ferme et cours d'eau
du secourisme les plus importants ceux
qui permettent de sauver une vie
ces gestes nous les avons résumé au
tableau vous voyez qu'il y a d'abord
empêcher l'aggravation empêcher
l'aggravation de l'accident et de l'état
du blessé ensuite savoir éviter la mort
par asphyxie vous savez que ce qu'il ya
de plus important dans le corps humain
c'est le cerveau et ce cerveau a besoin
d'oxygène pour vivre et pour qu'il
puisse avoir cet oxygène il faut que la
personne respire donc l' asphyxie est
quelque chose de très grave
nous verrons ce qu'il ya à faire pour
empêcher cette mort nous sommes aperçus
que cette personne ne respirait pas
parce que son thorax ne soulevait pas sa
tête qui repose sur le bureau est ainsi
la langue buts contre la gorge
il faut basculer la tête en arrière pour
ouvrir le passage aux clercs puisse
rentrer pour cela une main sera mise
sous la nuque l'autre main sur le front
le nez sera pincer la tête et basculé en
arrière et la bouche largement ouvert
on insuffle de l'air maintenant il
serait intéressant que vous souffriez
tous dans cette poupée pour apprendre le
geste si vous voulez commencer et la
tête bien en arrière il faut bien
écraser la bouche voilà on regarde les
thorax cbc en passant bien mener ensuite
savoir arrêter l'hémorragie c'est
évident le sang qui coule sur la route
va aggraver l'état du blessé
nous devons empêcher ce sang de couler
et à nous avons vu comment arrêter une
hémorragie en mettant un mouchoir et en
appuyant avec ce mouchoir sur la plaie
et à l'aide d'un deuxième lien ici notre
camarade a pris un mouchoir
eh bien il fait un noeud assez serré
pour bien arrêter l'hémorragie
un des gestes les plus importants du
secourisme etc et très souvent oubliée
c'est savoir donner la leyre qui alertés
comment alerter pour que les secours
arrivent tout de suite le docteur
chassaigne est de faire un cours de
secourisme
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais c'est
très utile
ce qu'on vient de faire ce n'est pas
parce que c'est bon si on se trouvent
des blessés une femme
dans un accident de voiture sur la route
on sera pas pris au sérieux si on
voulait faire quelque chose oui je ne
serais fait pas pris au sérieux si tu
voulais faire quelque chose mais il y a
des gestes très simples
par exemple savoir alerter j'ai des
exemples il ya un sapeur-pompier qui
reçoit qui a reçu un appel les visuels
peu chez moi et on raccroche
j'ai un ami qui est médecin dans une
dans l'agglomération parisienne
j'étais chez lui il ya quelques mois
pendant qu'il recevait un appel
téléphonique et cet appel était le
suivant n'évite docteur ya un mort dans
l'escalier et puis on raccroche
j'aimerais savoir à quel âge pourront
commencer ses études lui d'adapter les
notions en fonction de la pensée vous
aussi que le secourisme devrait être
obligatoire tout au moins que chacun
d'entre nous connaissent les gestes
principaux ne serait-ce que savoir
donner la leyre moi ça me plairait
beaucoup de consacrer mon temps aux
secours ils ça peut nous être très utile
dans la vie et pour aider beaucoup de
personnes et sauver des vies vous
acceptez de faire ça de faire une chose
comme ça graphiquement oui bien sûr oui
oui même quand vous travaillez les mêmes
quand vous gagnez de l'argent et que ça
je peux pas répondre sûrement mais je
pense quand même
je crois qu'il faut bien préciser que
ces cours de secourisme se font à
l'initiative des directeurs d'école
c'est ça le revers
une bannière minutes d'intervalle car
oui la réponse monsieur georges pompidou
président de république à la lettre que
lui a envoyée monsieur kossyguine sera
transmis cet après midi au président du
conseil sont vite
alain billoin en sport il y à un grand
retour celui de bambou oui c'est le
grand retour de roger bambuck demain à
l'occasion des championnats de france en
salle à l'institut national des sports
en bus que le meilleur sprinter français
qui fut rappelons le recordman du monde
du 100 m en 10 secondes à sacramento
s'était retiré après les jeux de mexico
en 1968
mon but que vous l'êtes alors se
consacrer à ses études après une année
d'interruption
il a repris son entraînement au début de
l'automne et on le reverra donc demain
sur 100 m contre starter saint-gilles
bourbeillon et médecins hier soir à
washington le président nixon a lui même
annoncé officiellement la candidature
des etats-unis pour l'organisation des
jeux olympiques de 1976 deux villes ont
été proposés los angelès pour les jeux
d'été et d'un verre pour les jeux
d'hiver
le comité olympique respectant une
certaine alternance pour l'organisation
des jeux alternance continental la
candidature américaine a les meilleures
chances d'être retenue plutôt que celle
de l'urss dont alain vit loin je pense
que l'événement aujourd'hui tous nos
maux sport ce sont les championnats
d'europe de patinage
oui effectivement les championnats
d'europe de patinage qui se poursuivent
aujourd'hui à leningrad avec les figures
libres dans l'épreuve réservée aux
couples et les imposer dame je ride and
we en os qu'on pourra voir un reportage
sur le rhône en journée
oui nous aurons un reportage sur la
première chaîne avec lyon zitrone à
partir de 17h thiercy enfin cet après
midi à vincennes il y aura 16 partants
dans le prix de châteaurenard
voilà je crois que vous avez à peu près
l'essentiel les prochaines informations
sont à 18h50 je vous remercie de votre
attention bonne après midi